once John wick steps inside the
Continental it quickly becomes apparent
that there is a lot to the underworld in
which he operates from its enigmatic
proprietor to the huge number of
interesting individuals who roam its
secret rooms the Continental is the key
to John wicks world generally speaking
the guests who check in to John wicks
Continental Hotel are allowed to do as
they please which is probably to be
expected given the consequences we say
of telling super assassins what to do
they can take advantage of a variety of
services enjoy a meal or a refreshing
drink and even get patched up with some
top-notch medical care that even the
nicest hotels don't usually offer
in-house there is however one activity
that is expressly prohibited on the
grounds you know the rules
no business can be conducted on these
premises lest incurring heavy penalties
and when they say business they're not
talking about accounting yes the
Continental is a safe haven for all the
assassins therein or it would be if we
didn't say someone breaking that rule in
every movie miss Perkins takes a
contract on John in the first film and
John himself crosses the line at the end
of the second the penalty for violating
this sacred rule well this isn't a world
full of assassins who don't fulfill
their job description in fact John's
violation of this rule is what sets up
the storyline of John wick three
Parabellum since the Continental Hotel
is our first introduction to the larger
criminal underworld of the John wick
universe it would be easy for us to get
lost upon entry
luckily the hotel's concierge helps to
introduce the audience to this
mysterious universe his name is Sharon
and it's a very fitting name for someone
with his occupation in Greek mythology
Charon spelled the same but pronounced
differently is the ferryman who took the
souls to the underworld across the river
Styx he required the debt to pay a toll
leading bodies to be bare
with a single gold coin something else
that's quite literal in the films so
they could pay the cover charge for the
afterlife
similarly John Wick's sharone seems able
to perform just about any service
including dog city if you pay him the
proper fee the one exception getting
bloodstains out of those fancy tailored
suits John favors our goods our laundry
I'm sorry to say that no one's that good
plus he's pretty formidable himself as
we find out in Parabellum if an
uninitiated person entered the hotel
without payment for sharone they might
find themselves down in the underworld
themselves before long speaking of the
gold coins that continually change hands
in the Continental Hotel it does appear
that the criminal underworld of John
wick operates under its own currency
system assassination contracts are paid
out in real world's money but the gold
coins the assassins throw around are
useful for a variety of different
criminal purposes according to the third
film the coins don't have a designated
value but they are what John and the
other assassins use for the variety of
goods and services that are offered at
the Continental they also serve as an
unofficial entry pass since so many
criminal businesses have disguised as
legitimate ones the coins let the
operator know whether the patron is here
for the legitimate service or a
nefarious one the coins have a Latin
phrase on each side one side reads X
only Tavey raised which is Latin for out
of unit strength the other side reads
ends causa sui
which means it is generated from itself
it seems this mysterious society has
existed for thousands of years the
global assassin community is overseen by
a cabal of powerful rich shadowy figures
who serve as an untouchable ruling class
known as the high table though they
appear to have a hand in nearly
everything that happens in the world of
John wick it does seem like the managers
of each individual branch of the
Continental Hotel have some say in how
their business operates we
Eston who runs New York City Continental
flexes some of his muscle when John
breaks the hotel's rules by killing
Santino deantonio inside although John
has been marked for death by the high
table Winston sends a group of waiting
assassins away and actually delays the
contract on John for one hour in order
to give him time to get a head start if
you hold this me
I mean chewed down to the bone
Winston seems to know that he can't
reverse the decisions of the high table
but he does have some power to delay and
interfere with their orders if he so
desires
speaking of Winston one constant
question that has not been answered is
just why the Continental hotels
proprietor is so chummy with John he
definitely has a soft spot for mr. wick
referring to him with familiarity as
Jonathan and keeping up with John's life
outside of the business he also seems
very concerned when John re-enters the
life and even more concerned when he has
to put a contract on his head why
and the way
a symbol answer might just be because of
John's professionalism and considerable
abilities or that he's also the
extremely charming Keanu Reeves the one
theory suggests that Winston may
actually be John's father-in-law is
mostly just speculation but it would
help explain Winston's relationship with
John a bit more is it possible that
Winston is the father of Helen Jon's
late wife sure is a likely probably not
but it would be a fun little wrinkle in
their relationship if you'd like to
experience the Continental for yourself
there's a way to do it without all the
shooting and gold coins checking out the
buildings where they shot the
Continental scenes the next time you
visit New York City yes that's hotels
they have actually used two different
buildings to stand in for the five-star
hitman Hotel the exteriors of the
Continental a shot at the Beaver
building it is located at one wall
street court if the intersections of
Wall Street Pearl Street and Beaver
Street the building was once the home of
the New York cocoa exchange and is
sometimes still referred to as such if
you want to experience the full
continental hotel however you'll need to
hit Delmonico's restaurant right down
the road at fifty-six Beaver Street this
historic steak house has been open since
1837 unless you have a pocket full of
gold coins you want to make a
reservation if you want some pictures
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you